Every time you explain your team's
coding standards to Claude, you're
repeating yourself.
Every PR review, you redescribe how you
want feedback [music] structured. Every
commit message, you remind Claude of
your preferred format.
And skills fix this.
A skill is a markdown file that teaches
Claude how [music] to do something once,
and Claude applies that knowledge
automatically whenever it's relevant.
Agent skills are folders of
instructions, scripts, and resources
that agents can discover and use to do
things more accurately and efficiently.
With Claude Code, we have the skill.md
file.
The description is how Claude decides
whether to use the skill. When you ask
Claude to review this PR, it matches
your request against available skill
descriptions and finds this one.
Claude reads your request, compares it
to all available skill descriptions, and
activates the ones that match.
You can store skills in a few places
depending on who needs them.
Personal skills go in the home directory
.claude/skills
and follow you across all your project.
These are your preferences, your commit
message style, your documentation
format, how you like code explained.
Project skills go in the .claude/skills
inside of the root directory of your
repository. Anyone who clones the
repository gets these skills
automatically. This is where team
standards live, like your company's
brand guidelines, preferred fonts, and
colors that you use for web design.
Claude Code has several ways to
customize behavior.
Skills are unique because they're
automatic and task-specific.
Claude.md files load into every
conversation. If you want Claude to
always use TypeScript strict mode, that
goes in your claw.md file. Skills, on
the other hand, load on demand when they
match your request. It only loads in the
name and description, so it doesn't fill
up your entire context window. Your PR
review checklist doesn't need to be in
the context when you're debugging.
It loads when you actually ask for a
review.
Slash commands require you to type them.
Skills don't.
Claude applies them when it recognizes
the situation.
Skills work best for specialized
knowledge that applies to specific
tasks.
Code review standards your team follows,
commit message formats that you prefer,
brand guidelines of your organization.
If you find yourself explaining the same
thing [music] to Claude repeatedly,
well,
that's a skill waiting to be written.